billionaires let's talk about the
billionaires the richest women
billionaires divorce that's the funniest
thing the most successful women got
their money why from my divorce should
be the IQ no no but I'm sorry but I'm
asking about outcomes so the women with
the most money how did they get there
was it was it through being so smart
incompetent
let's let's let's think about I'm
thinking about our female billionaires
one has a sex tape one sells makeup and
the others got their money through the
AmEx model and I work in healthcare when
Amex model you're you're a model I'm a
model okay and you work in healthcare
and I work in a healthcare yes okay
great and I have a black belt in karate
okay but I bet you he could still say
and if you say that Romans are not
clever no no she said she said the men
are more clever okay no I'm completely
disagree we can't